I know you want a peek at those planets
will be exploring and Mass Effect
Andromeda and I'm happy to oblige I'm
Tony this is a game spot news update and
for all the space game news be sure to
subscribe the main hook of Andromeda is
finding a new home for the human race
and the latest trailer gives us a look
at a few possibilities known as golden
worlds habitat one is a dry desert
planet with underground rivers habitat
to is a moon with a pretty red forest
habitat three is covered in jungles and
hills habitat for sports a bunch of
towering rock pillars and running rivers
habitat 5 features a purple
bioluminescent forest and habitat 6 is a
vast ocean with some mushroom looking
islands finally habitat 7 is described
as a tropical paradise and the trailer
states that this is where your journey
begins once you leave cryostasis so
hopefully one of those golden planets
works out Mass Effect Andromeda comes to
ps4 xbox one and pc on march 21st if you
want to revisit mass effect 3 in the
meantime check out the saddest party on
the Citadel gamespot's new series where
we try to kill off every member of
shepherds squad in the worst way
possible and for more lighthearted video
game news you're already in the right
place
[Music]
you